[Musique]
de nombreux aînés assiste un spectacle
de noël au ch et celle des de sainte
anne de beaupré
mais l'un des résidents lui ne fait que
passer en coup de vent notre notre fethi
québécois tout allait mourir
en effet un chef d nous on joue pas
jonathan marchand préfère le heavy metal
et les jeux vidéo
après tout il n'a que 43 ans ingénieur
informatique
il vit en ch et celle des deux puits
2012 en raison de sa dystrophie
musculaire
campant dans les maisons des lions
alternatif cette europe c'est la
figuration
enfin nous exclut le feuilleter malgré
son respirateur artificiel jonathan veut
mener une vie active
pour y arriver il propose un nouveau
programme destiné aux personnes
handicapées
l'assistance personnelle on veut plus se
contrôler des professionnels de santé
on veut créer une nouvelle profession
lui qui voit nous permettent de pouvoir
vivre sinon ses assistants de vie
seraient embauchés par la personne
handicapée elle même
l'état lui offrirait un budget plutôt
que de payer pour la maintenir en ch est
celle d une idée qui a du mérite selon
ce regroupement d'organismes pour
personnes handicapées s'il est vrai que
les budgets doivent pouvoir suivre les
personnes l'idée de corps pacistes elle
est viable
à l'heure actuelle les programmes
publics limitent les heures de service à
domicile
un problème majeur selon olivier cots
long des rames
quand on rentre en ch et celle des c'est
la dernière destination
il n'y a pas de plan de sortie alors
qu'il nous semble que même une personne
qu'on incarcère dans une prison on pense
qu'un jour elle va sortir puis avec un
projet comme coop assistons peut enfin
penser que les gens vont en avoir un
plan de sortie
jonathan a déjà proposé un projet pilote
au gouvernement on lui a dit non
notamment parce que son projet
nécessiterait des changements au code
des professions
mais nouvelle rencontre est prévue lundi
avec des représentants politiques
une lueur d'espoir pour lui vivent en
appartement avec ma conjointe ou à
travail y avoir une vie sociale normale
pour un voyage lui-même avoir introduit
comme tout le monde
jonathan estime qu'un projet pilote
coûterait entre 4 et 8 millions de
dollars ici alexandre duval radio-canada
beaupré